[Musique]
mélenchon jean luc 70 ans candidat la
france insoumise à l'élection
présidentielle c'est votre troisième
campagne bonjour et bienvenue jean luc
mélenchon bonjour nous allons donc
voyager avec vous dans les archives de
l'ina pour tenter de cerner votre adn en
commençant par vos premières apparitions
médiatiques rubrique big bang
la toute première image de vous date de
1981 et c'est un soir de victoire
électorale vous n'êtes pas encore dans
la lumière mais dans l'ombre d'un
candidat dont vous êtes le directeur de
cabinet claude germond le maire
socialiste de massy qui vient de sortir
le communiste pierre juquin dans la
troisième circonscription de l'essonne
vous avez 30 ans
claude germain vient proclamer les voix
obtenues dans sa ville
trente ans pas encore de demande d'amm
et déjà de l'ambition politique
ouais je l'ambition si vous voulez ça
j'étais un militant très très engagé
pour qui le militantisme politique est
une raison de vivre
et se trouve que je militais avec un
homme qui était extrêmement motivant il
était secrétaire confédérale de la cgt
et secrétaire national aux entreprises
pour le ps et donc sa manière d'être son
rapport au mouvement ouvrier
était pour moi un repère il était il a
été à repérer immense dans ma vie c'est
tout à fait évident et puis nous
partagions une certitude qu'ils veulent
peut-être vous surprendre on pensait
réellement qu'on allait faire le
socialisme donc si vous voulez les
questions du type carrière post s'était
pas vraiment le sujet quelques temps
après je suis devenu premier secrétaire
de la fédération socialiste de l'essonne
ce qui a été un grands seuil dans ma vie
politique
cette responsabilité si jeune à 30 ans
et donc je me suis installé directement
en situation de responsabilité politique
c'était très troublant parce que je suis
témoin de première ligne étant à cette
époque un cadre interne r du caractère
absolument est radicalement verticale
qu'on se faisait de l'idée du socialisme
et dans lequel le parti était en quelque
sorte l'avant-garde la conscience et
c'était lui qui disait ce qu'il fallait
faire si bien que quand il y a eu en
quelque sorte dans ses fans au g plat de
l'activité du mouvement uri après une
victoire pareil on s'attendait à une
explosion comparable à celle du front
populaire on avait tout ça dans la tête
et rien ne se passe si bien que les deux
premières années du socialisme réel en
france cent deux années d'inactivité
quasi totale des milieux populaires et
d'une ambiance épouvantable puisque nous
avons fait 3 ou 4 d'évaluation un
emprunt forcé
bon c'était c'était vraiment en contrôle
des changes voilà ce que j'ai au bout
donc on est on a été quasi immédiatement
mis en impasse et cette impasse a été
pour moi une brûlure parce que je ne le
supportais pas je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi rien ne se passait comme prévu
on va continuer de dérouler quelques
images de votre vie politique en 86 vous
êtes élu sénateur votre premier mandat
national et on vous retrouve l'année
d'après fervent soutien de sos racisme
et de son leader harlem désir
quoique harlem désir a apporté la preuve
qu'en parlant le langage des solutions
simples et concrètes mais aussi le
langage de la passion et après tout la
politique c'est une affaire de passion
bien faire de coeur eh bien on peut
convaincre et peut-être que il faut nous
mettre à cette école il faut savoir
parler à la fois le langage de la
passion et par les langages des
solutions simples et concrètes la
politique une affaire de passion plus
que le raison jean luc pelland les deux
mais je suis très surpris de cet extrait
j'en suis assez enthousiaste parce que
si vous voulez dans la période où j'ai
reformuler la quasi-totalité du cadre
conceptuel dans lequel j'évolue et c'est
à dire autour du livre l'ère du peuple
dans sa dernière version
justement on introduit le fait que la
politique ne peut pas être faite que de
raisonnement avec la prétention un peu
arrogante d'être la conscience qu'on va
injecter au zoo dans un schéma qui est
plus proche de celui du communisme que
de la forme de socialisme écologiques
auxquels moi j'appartiens mais il y
avait toujours si vous voulez on peut
pas se rendre compte aujourd'hui mais
s'assure plombé toute la gauche et là je
me trouve assez avancé puisque jeudi la
politique c'est de la théorie essais des
affects et ça ensuite ça a été un grand
lien mais pas le mot passion doit être
entendue au sens d'une adhésion
extrêmement intégrale de l'être dans ce
qu'ils pensent et ce qu'il ressent et
honnêtement je trouve ce passage assez
brillant je me reconnais de dans la
passion de la république elle vous
habitez vous l'avait incarné plusieurs
fois dans des moments graves en appelant
à l'unité nationale 27 mars 2018 à
l'assemblée nationale où salue ainsi le
colonel arnaud beltrame assassiné après
avoir pris la place d'un otage lors
d'une attaque terroriste
le lieutenant-colonel arnaud beltrame a
remis le monde humain en ordre il a
réaffirmé la primauté de la compassion
il a assumé la primauté d'un altruisme
absolu celui qui prend pour soi la mort
possible de l'autre illustrant ainsi les
valeurs de foi et de philosophie au
khalid était ta tâche personnellement en
ce sens le lieutenant-colonel
en ce sens
le lieutenant colonel beltrame est un
héros de la condition humaine
savoir trouver les mots ici pour se
hisser à la hauteur du drame là pour
convaincre et rassembler derrière soi
savoir trouver des mots c'est ce qu'il
ya de plus important pour l'expérience
sans doute ça fait partie de la mission
qui est celle d'un porte-parole moi je
me suis toujours vécu comme ça et puis
si vous voulez je ressens vivement
l'honneur d'être député de la république
française ou sénateur les différents
mandats que j'ai reçu ma famille était
d'abord comme vous l'imaginez je suis un
pied noir donc ma famille était très
algérie française mais il l'était au
sens républicain du terme si bien que
mon père qui était très algérie
française s'est séparé de la du camp
politique de l'algérie française quand
il a eu le sentiment que c'était de
contradictoire à l'esprit républicain et
n'ont donc élevée dans une ambiance si
vous voulez peut-être disproportionné de
damour quasi aveugle et pour la patrie
républicaine je vais vous faire sourire
mais à partir du moment la dernière
année j'ai vécu au maroc s'étaient tous
les dimanches mes parents mettaient la
musique militaire et savoir pourquoi
mais ça fait que je connais toutes les
sonneries de l'armée française mais
trouver les mots quand on est un député
oui c'est une fonction et arnaud
beltrame en plus me ça me parle je suis
pas un homme indifférent ce que je vis
ni aux événements savent pas ce qu il
fait tellement extraordinaire il se
propose d'aller mourir à la place des
autres et il était à la fois chrétien
pratiquant et franc-maçon ce qui a été
le cas de beaucoup de gens qui m'ont
entouré pendant une partie de ma vie
donc j'ai essayé si vous voulez de
m'emplit re de ce que lui avaient à cet
instant mis en mouvement au service des
autres alors si j'ai rendu service je
crois l'avoir fait parce que j'ai reçu
un très beau message
de son épouse eh bien je suis fier j'ai
fait mon travail j'ai été un bon député
pour la france souvent vos mots sont
tranchants votre arrivée et celle d'un
combattant florilège
[Musique]
ma manière d'être est un signal je suis
le bruit et la fureur ceci est une
insurrection citoyenne via ne sera
rentré dans son lit le fleuve qui est en
train de déborder
nous devons
expédié à terre le pouvoir de la droite
qui vous élyséen ces trois là vous allez
craché du sang sera empêchée d'entrer
dans mon local on n'est pas des voyous
on n'est pas du bandit la république se
voit pas encore au dessus à risque iam
very dangerous
les mots sont des armes ils peuvent être
des pièges avez vous le sentiment
parfois de vous être laissés griser par
vos paroles dans leur pare-brise et non
balisés des erreurs ça c'est tout à fait
évident des fois des erreurs
d'évaluation parce que je croyais très
bien inspiré de m appeler le bruit et la
fureur
parce que je pensais que les
commentateurs avaient tous lui il faut
sévir en avant roman est en fait ça
s'est complètement retournée contre moi
parce que les gens sont dit mais ce type
i complètement énervé bon c'est raté bon
ca testés vers de shakespeare après il
ya d'autres fois où c'est pas j'ai été
grisé c'est que tout d'un coup j'ai été
débordé par ce que je ressentais dans la
scène qu'on voit ou jeudi la république
c'est moi dont on a fait des t-shirts
depuis et des plaisanteries
bon cet homme menace de son arme il me
dit monsieur je suis armé il me montre
son petit son petit truc tricolore et à
ce moment là si vous voulez comment nous
expliquer c'est ridicule je sais bien
mais je suis rempli d'une indignation le
terrible parce que je veux la république
c'est moi c'est pas lui c'est moi qui
suis député qui sut maltraités à ce
moment là où qui le ressens comme ça bon
voilà alors ça ça a été des moments
mais vous savez je suis pas le premier
dans l'histoire un des modèles
politiques qui ont souvent fait
réfléchir
forte densité en ancien régime comme ça
ça va un peu mettre du sel dans
l'émission
j'ai été en lecteur très assidu des très
attentif de la biographie de louis 11
par paul murray kendall qui a commencé
une magnifique collection su fayard de
biographies et le roi lyon ce qui est
est un sommet de l'habileté de
l'intelligence politique dit à un moment
donné ma langue n'aura coûté cher je
peux dire que la mienne aussi m'a coûté
cher mais d'autres moments elle a été là
à mon service pour
tout d'un coup mettre plus grand que moi
en scène qui étaient les idées que que
j'illustre et mais non bien sûr que
c'est pas assez pas tous des coûts au
but à roanne là je ne vous imaginait pas
vous comparant alloué 11 lisez la
biographie l'élu il n'y a aucun moment
je me propose à présent jean-luc
mélenchon de déterrer vos racines
[Musique]
vous l'avez livre racines sont
méditerranéenne mais de l'autre côté
vous êtes né en 1951 tanger qui avait
alors un statut international avant de
revenir au maroc indépendant 56 voici
tanger à cette époque dans les
actualités françaises
tanger un nom de ville qui trouvent des
échos dans le monde entier
située à la charnière de l'europe et de
l'afrique riche d'un passé qui rejoint
la mythologie dans l'imagination des
hommes tanger rassemblent au flanc de la
montagne ses maisons ses mosquées ses
ruelles animées et cosmopolite
[Musique]
autrefois par et du prestige ambiguë de
ville internationale danger aujourd'hui
fait partie intégrante du royaume
qu'est ce qu'il vous reste de ses années
d'enfance à tanger d'un émerveillement
dont je fais pas partie des gens qui
croient tous eu tout ce truc sur les
racines
moi j'aime le futur mais je vous le dis
vive pour le mentionner un je n'en veux
à personne que l'on trouve important de
se situer en arrière de soi mais de
tanger d'abord l'émerveillement de
l'enfance on regrette tous notre enfance
mais si vous voulez c'est ce monde et
nous y que c'était d'abord d'un côté la
méditerranée de l'autre côté
l'atlantique donc le dimanche quand tes
parents faisait pique nique avec leurs
amis on choisissait si on allait au cap
spartel ou cap malabata ensuite il y
avait une sorte de du mix pure du peuple
d'albi de langue qui est qui était
extraordinaire et à l'école française
d'abord l'école perrier puis l'école
berchet dans ma classe nous devions être
je sais pas moi sur trente
six petits français et puis les autres
étaient des espagnols il y avait un ou
deux marocains pas pas beaucoup il faut
il faut bien le dire et donc on vivait
en permanence dans une sorte de
d'internationalisme
active c'est comme ça d'ailleurs que
j'ai appris à parler l'espagnol parce
que la langue que tout le monde utilisé
la langue commune c'était l'espagnol et
mes parents parler l'espagnol l'anglais
et l'arabe mois et là je ne parle pas
l'arabe mais j'ai appris à parler aussi
l'anglais si bien que si vous voulez
parler plusieurs langues n'était pas une
chose bizarre pour moi on avait toujours
fait comme ça là vous êtes en train de
montrer les grottes des reculs car vous
savez que c'est hercules qui a séparé
l'afrique de l'europe et on va voir la
grotte où il l'a opérée cette cette
opération donc pour moi c'est tout ça
est naturellement une un attachement une
bonhomie du lien au monde musulman parce
que le royaume du maroc est un art et
image ultra majoritairement la
population est de confession musulmane
donc si vous voulez je n'ai jamais
souffert des peurs paniques et des
angoisses raciste qui accable les autres
parce que ça nous jamais posé de
problème j'ai compris qu'on n'avait pas
la même religion les miens étaient
catholiques et je l'étais aussi il y
avait plusieurs petits qui a lieu à la
synagogue là et puis d'autres à rien du
tout je suppose enfin bon si ce n'est
pas un sujet n'était pas un sujet la
religion mais marqué par le marqué par
la douleur de l'exil ah oui oui oui
c'est
ça c'est terrible c'est terrible parce
que n'en voit que je ne sais même pas
pourquoi on est parti nous étions au
maroc il n'y avait aucun risque au maroc
mais la population européenne
et s'est envolé comme une bande
d'étourneaux affolé de du maghreb à
partir du moment où il y a eu
l'indépendance de l'algérie et tout ça a
été totalement disproportionnée nous
n'avions aucune raison de quitter le
maroc maroc s'est battu pour son
indépendance il ya eu des luttes
meurtrière info faut pas croire que où
que ce soit la puissance coloniale était
sympathique mais si vous voulez une fois
que le maroc est devenu indépendant il a
récupéré ses frontières il n'y a plus
aucune difficulté j'ai même le plaisir
amusé de me souvenir que ma première
manifestation les mets donc cinq ans
c'est parce que j'avais croisé avec mon
père et mon oncle une manifestation qui
réclamaient le retour du roi mohamed6
est alors volé gens dans la rue crier 5
yahia ben youssef grandval alors ça
voulait dire rendez-nous benyoucef sidi
mohammed ben youssef monsieur grandval
gouverneur général et donc je rentre à
la maison tout content d'avoir vu ces
hommes si banal si courageux je me mets
à faire le tour de la table en criant il
ya ben youssef grandval bon side pas été
très appréciée dans la maison mais ma
première manif c'est pour l'indépendance
du maroc et le retour du roi du maroc
dans son royaume est comme ça en mai 68
vous avez 16 ans mais ce qui vous
marquent c'est moins l'éclosion du
printemps de la jeunesse que
l'écrasement du printemps de prague
quant au lendemain de vaud 17 ans le 20
août 68 les chars russes envahissent la
tchécoslovaquie
[Musique]
moi je suis ché j'habite prague et
j'étais là en smart à vous les blindés
sont arrivés pris par des chars et des
soldats est tout de même pour moi et
pour nous tous étaient fiers de
l'occupation alou c'était quelque chose
de terrible parce que
c'était à l'amour jeunes qui étaient
tués un amour pour la liberté et c'est
pour ça que vous voyez aussi que les
jeunes qui se pose c'est est partout la
question de la jeunesse on peut dire
jean luc mélenchon vous êtes un révolté
de 68 mais du printemps de prague je me
suis rampa seulement j'étais enraciné à
ce moment-là sam enraciné dans une thèse
que je vais ensuite développé qu'elle
non alignement parce que jusque là on
était très hostile aux américains au
vietnam aux agents orange aux
bombardements abominable par lesquels
ils essayaient de s'imposer aux
vietnamiens mais si vous voulez bon
l'urss était un peu l'angle mort il y
avait des copains communiste on n'allait
pas s'engueuler j'étais jeune 17 ans
donc je rentre pas trop dans les détails
et l'invasion de la tchécoslovaquie c1
c'est un coup terrible pourquoi parce
que le peuple tchèque
comment dire le soulèvement on appelait
ça le socialisme à visage humain les
dirigeants du parti communiste tchèque
était partisan de cette révolution de
cette deuxième révolution socialiste en
tchécoslovaquie avait des deux pays à
l'époque c'est pas deux pays séparés et
donc je voulais c'était une horreur à
l'état pur
et pour des jeunes gens qui se disaient
abc formidable le monde va changer
comment c'était possible et donc on
découvrait tout d'un coup que non
seulement il nous faudrait affronter
l'impérialisme américain je parle avec
le vocabulaire de l'époque mais aussi
l'ogre stalinien capable d'envahir des
pays juste pour les mater et les
contrôler
si bien que à partir de là mon
engagement a eu deux faces et j'ai été
beaucoup engagée contre le stalinisme
toute ma vie jusqu'à à peu près
gorbatchev ou là le monde a commencé à
changer
j'ai aussi un peu commencé à bouger mais
c'est à toutes les campagnes c'est cet
événement qui vous conduit au trotskysme
plutôt qu'au communisme de lui oui sinon
je sais pas ce que je serais devenu le
communisme n'avait pas une grande faveur
dans ma famille mais bon comme il était
de droite j'étais pas concernés par
leurs opinions
mais peut-être que j'aurais été poussé à
me tourner vers eux surtout que j'étais
un admirateur absolument échevelé de la
conquête spatiale parole et russes pour
moi gagarine c'est l'équivalent du ta
mère c'est le moment où l'humanité
franchi une frontière absolue un mot
encore sur ce qu'on vient de voir et 68
la tchécoslovaquie est-ce qu'en voyant
kiev vous avez pensé à prague
au mois pour un point le courage
absolument incroyable des gens qui
montent sur les chars pourparlers avec
les gars qui sont dedans
parce que le
tchèque slovaquie aussi des gens on n'a
pas vu sur vos images mais c'était une
image très classique on voyait des gens
montées sur les chars et souvent c'était
des communistes qui parlait aux gens
qu'ils avaient dans le char leur disant
mais qu'est ce que tu fous là rentre
chez toi ta rennes a fait agir trouver
quelque chose
en ukraine de ceux de ce courage
incroyable parce que honnêtement en
monter sur un char faut le faire quoi ce
n'est pas à la portée de tout le monde
et je crois que oui j'ai pensé à ça mais
naturellement je savais que ça n'avait
plus rien à voir
parce que là ya ni socialiste ni
communisme qui soit en cause il a un
côté ni de l'autre on parle d'autre
chose c'est le droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux-mêmes et avoir leurs
frontières qui ne soient pas violés
tandis que là les russes ont changé
l'histoire du monde nous savons tous le
l'invasion de l'ukraine est un grand
tournant de l'histoire du monde alors
attendez que la poussière retombe mais
ils ont pris une initiative que personne
ne leur pardonnera jamais c'est d'avoir
violé une frontière en plein europe et
d'avoir bombardé des populations civiles
en pleine europe moi je veux bien qu'on
me dise qu'on en a fait autant en serbie
mais non c'est pas de même nature parce
que la russie est un pays nucléaire et
il a donc faire un chantage là en ce
moment il fait un chantage insupportable
il dit bah allez faites quelque chose
pour voir il ils savent très bien que ne
déclencheront pas une guerre nucléaire
c'est donc la première fois qu'on voit
s'appliquer la stratégie du fou au fort
et nous met au pied du mur d'une action
que personne n'a envie d'avoir à savoir
la guerre nucléaire c'est d'une gravité
qui est pas comparable à celle de 68 est
beaucoup plus grave 68 bon après coup
sur le moment ça me paraissait horrible
et j'ai pleuré comme une madeleine mais
il y avait si vous voulez l'avenir un
style ouvert là on a l'impression qu'ils
l'ont fermée je reviens à vos
engagements jean luc mélenchon vous avez
aussi été franc-maçon c'est un
engagement dont vous avez parlé
librement membres à partir des années 80
du grand orient de france dont voici le
grand maître roger leray à l'occasion
des assises de la laïcité qui
l'organisait en 1981
tentons pas de la laïcité en évoque
toujours des combats d'un autre temps
qui se justifiait mais la laïcité
défense des droits de l'homme la laïcité
obligation pour les hommes te donner à
chaque petit donne les moyens d'être
lui-même de son accomplissement la
laïcité pose toujours problème et doit
être défendue avec
vigueur je répète pour nous la laïcité
c'est d'abord évidemment en
enseignements un enseignement non
ségrégatif
mais c'est aussi tout à fait autre chose
et et notamment la défense absolue des
droits de l'homme et le droit pour
chacun d'être comme disait diderot
propriétaire de soi
c'est toujours votre vision
est le grand maître roger leur est un
personnage extrêmement attachant qui a
joué un rôle dans l'histoire de france
qui est peut-être méconnu c'est de la
participation très intense qu'il a eu à
au dégagement d'une issue pacifique en
nouvelle-calédonie donc on doit beaucoup
de respect à cet homme je suis toujours
sur sebha j'entends ce qu'il dit bon il
est grand maître du grand orient pas
responsables politiques
quand il dit qu'il y ait un lien intime
philosophique entre la question de la
séparation des églises et de l'état et
l'idée que tout ça repose sur l'idée que
l'être humain et constructeurs de lui
même il a cité diderot on pourrait citer
puis de la mirandole parce que c'est à
ce moment là que ça commence vers 14
cents la fin du xvème siècle
c'est-à-dire l'être humain étant
responsable de son histoire il
n'accomplit pas un salut il n'accomplit
pas une destinée il est l'auteur de son
histoire ça c'est l'idée fondamentale
mais il me semble que rj ellory à ce
moment là mais il faut le mettre dans le
contexte de 1980 où les idées étaient
beaucoup plus simple plus clair
qu'aujourd'hui
il ne faut pas méconnaître que la
liberté de conscience en france c'est à
dire le droit de penser ce qu'on veut
comme on veut et de changer d'avis elle
est née la fille de la liberté du culte
souvent on oublie ça c'est à dire que
c'est dans la guerre de religion entre
catholiques et protestants
c'est inextricable il ya qu un dieu en
plus elle-même il ya quinze
représentants c'est le christ et on
l'honore pas de la même manière dont ce
titan casse tête pour eux ils se sont
entretués beaucoup et puis à la fin on
finit par dire bon bah chacun fait
pratiquer le culte comme il le croire ça
a mis du temps d'entre entre la période
dont on parle a faim il ya eu des
épisodes tragiques louis xiv abrogeant
l'édit de nantes en fin de tout ça
c'était des horreurs la france est donc
un pays unique en europe parce qu' elle
n'a pas réglé la querelle religieuse
entre catholiques et protestants par des
massacres de masse comme en espagne ou
en italie ou en allemagne il par une
partition du territoire comme ça a été
fait en allemagne il disait que youth
regio ejus religio c'est à dire tu es de
la religion de ton roi si tu en aurais
protestante et protestante est pas
content tu vas dans l'état à côté nous
on n'a pas réglé ça comme ça on
l'araignée d'une manière magnifique et
héroïque mais il faut bien se rappeler
que la laïcité n'est pas un athéisme
d'état quand on parle de l'état 1 après
la philosophie personnelle c'est autre
chose alors j'ai quitté le mouvement
francs-maçons parce que je ne faisais
plus rien depuis plus de dix ans donc je
trouve que c'était pas très respectueux
pour ceux qui travaillaient et puis il y
avait des choses qui me dérangeait comme
partout rien de grave mais
trop pour que jean supporter davantage
allons à présent chercher vos mentors
françois mitterrand évidemment en
septembre 87 à quelques mois de la fin
de son premier mandat vous écrivez avec
d'autres une lettre à françois
mitterrand pour lui demander de se
représenter nous sommes en pleine
cohabitation quelques mois après les
manifestations contre la loi devaquet
françois mitterrand il a apporté la
preuve notamment pendant les événements
de novembre et décembre dernier qu'il
avait cette capacité d'écouté
d'attention à ce qui est nouveau dans la
société française à ce qui bouge lui il
avait besoin de se mettre en route man
sur la tête pour avoir leurs jeunes
d'ailleurs ils n'essayent pas de quoi
quand on regarde par exemple ce que
disent les jeunes autour de nous ce que
disent les sondages il ya une confiance
il ya une sympathie à l'égard de
françois mitterrand qui est très fort
très profonde c'est pas pour rien qu'on
l'appelle ton temps
qu'est-ce qu'il a été pour vous
mitterrand un guide un modèle une
admiration d'abord
j'étais un partisan de du programme
commun et de l'union de la gauche mais
je faisais plus confiance au parti
socialiste qu'au parti communiste qui
étaient deux partis réformistes de
manière différente et moi je vous
rappelle que je venais du trotskisme non
que je cherchais un point d'équilibré
entre mes convictions révolutionnaires
qui n'ont pas changé puisque je n'aime
pas plus la société capitaliste ses
valeurs et ses fondamentaux que à
l'époque et françois mitterrand le
chapeau le des sharks en écharpe rouge
de pardessus à grammont j'ai toujours
aimé les chapeaux et vous là vous vous
pointer le doigt sur une souffrance
terrible chaque fois je mets ce chapeau
on me dit qu'ils menaient chapeau de
françois mitterrand mais non j'aime les
chapeaux bon j'aime les cravates aussi
figurer vos bref alors françois
mitterrand était l'homme qui incarnait
ça et puis il m'a dit est arrivé à un
moment de ma vie où je l' ai vu exécuter
une figure théorico stratégique
extraordinaire maintenir le cap de
l'union de la gauche alors que plus
personne n'en voulait ni les communistes
qui avaient rompu ni en interne les amis
de monsieur michel rocard et lui tient
bon et c'est ça qu'il fallait faire à ce
moment là pour unifier le peuple france
son idée c'était que
l'union au sommet était un moyen de
l'union à la base mais quand l'union au
sommet s'est dérobée il est allé sur
l'union à la base en leur disant mais
voilà moi le programme c'est exactement
la méthode que je déploie aujourd'hui
peut-être avec moins de talent que lui
mais à l'époque les choses se sont
passées comme ça et puis voilà moi je
suis un petit je viens durant mes
parents ne suis pas n'est qu'une
cuillère d'argent dans la bouche le
président de la république m'a fait le
le privilège la faveur de s'intéresser à
moi de me recevoir de parler avec moi et
donc petit à petit une sorte d'affection
je n'étais pas danser ses principaux
prochain j'étais donc je sais pas
peut-être une fenêtre pour lui un homme
qu'ils n'avaient pas 40 ans ensuite a
fini par les avoirs et avec qui il
parlait et moi je lui suis reconnaissant
de de tous ces moments que j'ai trouvé
magique plus de sa fabuleuse
intelligence stratégique il ya forcément
des aspects de de mitterrand qu'il
devait - vous plaire mitterrand
l'européen ou mitterrand l'atlantiste
discours fameux de 83 lors d'un voyage
officiel en belgique
je suis moi aussi qu'outre les 0,8
seulement je constate des choses tout
était simple dans le débat actuel
le pacifisme et tout ce qu'il recouvre
il est à l'ouest et les euromissiles ils
sont à l'est
et
je pense qu'il s'agit là de rapport
inégal
mitterrand l'a aligné sur les positions
de l'otan il vous déçoit non non je suis
toujours d'accord avec lui non mais oh
non alignés il ne veut ni de l'un ni de
l'autre que les soviétiques vient
d'installer des missiles à nos portes
c'est encore le cas avec les russes
puisque vous savez que je ne cesse de
répéter qu'il faut qu on met ça dans la
discussion les missiles cinq sens à 1000
km aujourd'hui ça n'intéresse plus grand
monde les questions de défense mais moi
ça m'a toujours passionné donc on a
toujours ce sujet non l'europe ne doit
pas être un théâtre de guerre dont vous
remballer tout votre matériel et quant
aux américains ils ont déployé des
batteries antimissiles en pologne qui
sont une menace directe pour la russie
je suis pour qui remballe aussi là je
pense que l'on a fait une énorme erreur
d'accepter un truc pareil donc non je
suis alors lui ce qui est vrai dans ce
que vous dites c'est que françois
mitterrand se sentait spontanément sans
doute plus proche des américains que des
russes mais je suis quand même témoin de
première ligne que quand on a parlé de
la guerre du golfe que je n'ai pas
appuyé alors qu'il était président et
j'étais horriblement mal heureux à
l'idée de me séparer de lui je lui ai
écrit il m'a dit mais ça c'est pareil
mais pourquoi j'admets qu'on pense
différemment venez voir l'honneur
suprême nous voilà donc dans la
bibliothèque et lui m'a parlé de la
tentative qui avait fait la france
jusqu'au bout pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'intervention militaire et lui me dit a
dit à ce moment-là mais saddam hussein
est un crétin parce qu'il n'a même pas
accepté un calendrier de retrait ce qui
était à l'époque une évidence adam
aurait épargné l'irak s'il avait eu
l'intelligence de comprendre qu'il
fallait reculer exactement ce que
monsieur poutine n'a pas en ce moment
comme intelligence de comprendre qu'il
va falloir qu'il recule et que personne
ne lui pardonnera ce qu'il a osé faire
une fois donc non je me reconnais bien
en ligne mais c'est vrai qu'il est plus
lui comme on dit compte tenu de sa
génération aussi à cela que moi j'ai
assez clair c'est clair moi je pour moi
les si vous voulez pour lui les
américains font partie du process de la
libération de la france et à kehl au
plan pour moi les russes aussi mais bon
voilà moi je la guerre du vietnam n'ont
quoi oui ça me va tout à fait la même
génération bien sûr un autre mentor
celui là de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
et pas du tout attentiste au venezuela
c'est hugo chavez
quant aux autres chavez vient à la
rencontre des femmes d'associations de
gauche des militantes d'organisations
caritatives de ces mères de familles des
quartiers populaires
elles l'acclament comme si déjà ils
venaient de remporter l'élection
présidentielle
le 6 décembre
vous les enfants de simon bolivar vise à
les briser les chaînes de l'esclavagé
ces chaînes qui entravent le venezuela
et vous allez balayé ces politiciens
pourris toute cette pourriture
qu'ils s'en aillent tous
pourquoi chavez jean luc mélenchon il
arrive vous savez j'ai une longue
histoire commune avec l'amérique latine
depuis les années 70 le coup d'état de
pinochet donc j'ai été très lié à la
mouvance politique latino d'abord très
chili puis argentine ce sont des pays en
plus qui m'ont fait l'honneur de
souligner ma participation à cette lutte
puisque l'on a quand même sauvé des gens
et puis si vous voulez à un moment donné
non je y mon saoul et je ne comprenais
plus rien à ce qu'ils aient on n'était
pas bien on n'avait pas fait tout ça
pour se retrouver à la fin dans des
combines politiciennes auquel je
comprenais rien au chili et ailleurs
tant et si bien que comme pendant ce
temps la gauche s'effondraient dans
toute l'europe j'étais à l'affût et je
n'ai jamais eu une mentalité si vous
voulez de dominateur donc je regarde ce
que font les autres les afriques a
maintenant beaucoup et puis à l'époque
les latinos beaucoup et voilà comment
dans le paysage au départ moi mon
s'était pas de chaves et ça ailleurs ça
n'a jamais été que cha m c'est elle ou
là parce qu'il avait constitué un grand
parti le parti des travailleurs j'ai été
très lié à eux et puis après ça a été
rafael correa dans en équateur est
évidemment tu avais cela au mieux mais
comme j'avais c'était la tête à claques
de la gauche raisonnable française et de
toute la droite balmont assimilé à
chavez bon c'est à une méthode de combat
politique l'ancien me faire pareil avec
poutine là ça a été un peu plus
compliqué parce que je n'ai jamais eu
d'autres relations que confie thuel avec
le système poutinien tandis qu'avec
chavez non c'était j'ai regardé faire
j'ai regardé comment il s'y prenait
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchaient à faire et
surtout il avait un rôle personnel qui
m'a beaucoup appris deux choses il était
tout le temps en contact avec les autres
présidents latino de gauche c'est lui
qui était là le pivot de tout ça alors
après évidemment il a évolué dans une
telle adversité que
bon là bas le ton monte sans arrêt bon
mais en vue d'europe vous savez c'est
toujours pareil fouquières méchants et
les gentils donc
l'europe a décidé que monsieur le pen
était le méchant et le gentil c'est
l'autre le trafiquant de drogue qui aux
états unis d'amérique m'enfin ça compte
pas pour moi ça n'a pas d'importance car
l'important c'est ce que j'ai vu les
leçons que j'ai tiré ce que j'ai appris
en les regardant faire en bien et en mal
ce que moi je ne ferais pas si je vous
retrouver devant la même situation que
la rubrique suivante est celle des
évolutions ou des revirements 180°
[Musique]
l'extrême droite second tour de la
présidentielle en 2002 comme en 2017
mais votre réaction n'est pas la même
5 mai il faut pas hésiter alors mettez
des gants si vous voulez dépasse tout ce
que vous voulez mais votez fait abaisser
le bape cycle ben chacun chacune d'entre
vous
cette en conscience quel est son devoir
qu'est ce qui a changé en quinze ans
dans le contexte la première fois je
suis un dirigeant socialiste
je parle j'étais ministre en plus je
crois en ses le oui c'est vrai donc
j'étais vraiment très liées à toute la
mouvance socialiste que je avec laquelle
j'avais des divergences mais surtout une
adhésion à ses profondes et puis nous
étions absolument sidéré par ce qu'il
venait de se passer on n'arrivait pas à
y croire on avait conscience du danger
mes pieds tête qui dépassaient la raison
moi j'ai fait une tribune pour dire
qu'il fallait aller voter chirac les
j'ai fait beaucoup de choses de cette
nature le quand on arrive à la dernière
fois la situation est complètement
différente la gauche ait explosé je suis
à la tête d'un ensemble politique qui en
gros se situe dans la philosophie de
gauche mais n'a pas assez d'histoire il
existe depuis à peine deux ans n'a pas
assez d'histoire pour que ils se sentent
liés à une option que proclame le
responsable en l'occurrence moi donc je
me suis dit comment je me sors de ça
pour pas faire de bêtises c'est à dire
que si je m'étais j'étais arrivé en
disant ah ben écoutez maintenant c'est
clair on fait comme la première fois on
vote pour pour macron contre le pen je
provoquer une déflagration parce que
plein de gens n'étaient pas prêts à
entendre un discours pareil donc j'ai
dit vous savez ce que vous avez à faire
est la ruse c'est qu'on a ouvert comme
on le ferait sans doute grand dans
d'autres occasions comparables un vote
parmi les gens qui parrainait ma
candidature et on n'a mis que deux
options un vote et maquereau ou
s'abstenir et on a dit ben voilà la
réponse elle est là c'est vous tous qui
décidez quelle est la consigne que l'on
nomme et je crois que c'est une méthode
qui a assez bien fonctionné après je
dois la loyauté de ne pas vous dire ce
que moi même j'ai fait mais la loyauté à
l'égard de ceux qui ont voté pour moi et
qu'ils attendaient que j'ai cette façon
de parler mes adversaires en ont profité
pour dire que je mettais jeu égal signe
égal entre maquereau et le pen c'est bon
c'est de la basse polémique d'ailleurs
vous auriez pu montrer l'extrait où je
dis il doit pas y avoir une seule voie
pour le pen écoutez quand il ya deux
candidats avec vous il faut pas qu une
seule voie pour en d2 vont tout le monde
comprend mais je ne pouvais pas compte
tenu de ce qui était le mot rapport à
ceux qui m'avaient mandaté 7 millions de
voix c'était la première fois qu'une
chose pareille arrive et qu'un candidat
comme ils disent de la gauche radicale
incarne à ce poids un mouvement
populaire aussi profond donc je pense
que j'ai réagi correctement parce que si
j'avais agi autrement j'aurais plutôt
brutalisés ou indignés ce qui n'était
pas le but de l'opération le but de
l'opération ce n'est que madame le pen
ne perde
rubriques suivantes
zéro pointé c'est la séquence des
dérapages ou des sorties de route celle
ci date de juin dernier sur france inter
à propos de la campagne présidentielle à
venir
vous verrez dans la dernière semaine de
la campagne présidentielle nous aurons
un grave incident alors ça a été tout un
meurtre ça a été mais ras en 2012 ça a
été l'attentât la dernière semaine sur
les champs elysées vous rappeler de tout
ça c'était la dernière semaine avant on
a bu papy voise tout ça c'est écrit
d'avenches qu'avez vous voulu dire ce
jour là
me souviens plus qui avait très peu de
temps alors j'ai essayé de dire je
suppose j'ai essayé de dire écoutez il
ya une manière de mettre en scène les
élections qui peuvent être terribles le
véritable se souvenir le plus
traumatisant pour moi c'était papy voise
parce que on a eu droit à cet homme dans
la maison et les terres l'incendié puis
ensuite on a découvert que tout ça a été
beaucoup plus compliqué que ce qu'on
croyait pendant tout le week-end où
lionel jospin était éliminé puisqu'il
nous a manqué deux voies dans chaque
bureau de vote pour qu'ils soient au
deuxième tour vous savez pour moi le
l'élimination de lionel jospin c'est un
tournant dans l'histoire de france parce
que
voilà le futur à partir de là a été
dessiné par ce deuxième tour est il à
obséder les français pendant je ne sais
combien d'années puisqu'on 2017 au ça
continue on a un deuxième tour avec
l'extrême droite et ensuite on ne parle
que de ça immigration sécurité dresse
alors j'ai voulu dire qu'il y avait une
manière d'utiliser les circonstances
mais ça a été fait d'une manière
tellement malhabile et tellement le
trait tellement
de valloire ça fonctionne pas quoi on
comprend pas ce que je veux dire vous
même vous dites mais qu'est ce que vous
avez voulu dire au juste et puis après
il s'est produit si vous voulez que les
journalistes étaient sur le plateau
personne n'a vu malice dans sa sur le
moment personne m'a dit mais qu'est ce
que vous êtes en train de raconter bon
alors on a fini les missions et ce sont
des militants politiques qui ont relevé
ce bout pour en faire une histoire mais
moi j'ai mis du temps à réagir pourquoi
parce que le lundi on découvre une vidéo
dans laquelle un membre d'extrême droite
se proposait de me tuer ainsi quelques
amis et on le voyait avec un fusil et
tout donc nous étions absolument atterré
par par cette violence et donc j'étais
cours à 100% en train de me préoccuper
de ça tandis que le dimanche soir de
cette émission j'étais dans le résultat
d'une élection partielle si vous voulez
ça fait un enchaînement qui fait que ce
truc là même à glisser entre les doigts
quoi je dis j'ai vu l'événement
ni j'étais là à temps pour le reprendre
dire écoutez stop rembobine le film vais
vous expliquer ça autrement mais là
honnêtement je me rappelle même plus ce
que je voulais dire une grande figure
l'histoire de france dont l'ombre plane
sur cette campagne il a été souvent cité
nous allons vous mettre face à de gaulle
[Musique]
de gaulle père d'une vème république que
vous voulez liquidés et promoteurs en 62
d'une élection qui structure depuis
notre vie politique
c'est
le projet
que je vous soumets
propos
que le président de la république votre
président soit élu dorénavant pas vous
mais
rien n'est plus républicain
rien n'est plus démocratique
j'ajoute que rien n'est plus français
tant cela est clair
simple et droit
rien de plus républicain de plus
démocratique de plus français que lui
auriez vous répondu jean luc mélenchon à
l'époque oui obame et mes prédécesseurs
se sont chargés de dire des bêtises donc
je savais difficile de revenir dessus
bon ils l'ont décrit comme un fasciste
comme bon tout ça est pas vrai ça a été
ça a été stupide de l'accusé de ça moi
ce que je vois c'est un homme qui a une
intelligence stratégique et tactique
absolument immense que rien n'arrête
aucune audace ne retient
car lorsqu'il dit y'a rien de plus
républicain que d'élire le président de
la république au suffrage universel il
sollicite un peu l'histoire la
république peut prendre bien des formes
en disons ça aussi on va pas faire de
lui un anti républicain mais le
plébiscite personnel l'histoire de
france en est rempli et la gauche n'a
jamais approuvé ça c'est napoléon iii
bon c c'est le général boulanger chaque
fois qu on personnalise
boulanger était candidat des
législatives mais bref en france il ya
toujours une grosse méfiance à l'égard
du personnage solitaire qui incarne le
pouvoir maintenant mais aujourd'hui
c'est rentrer dans nos moeurs
honnêtement complètement puis ça
ruisselle sur la société absolut à dire
qu'il ya le grand chef au sommet des
institutions politiques les moyens chef
les petits chefs et puis tout le monde
est celle que vous êtes conscient qu'il
serait difficile de convaincre des
français de leur ôter ce droit alors
je ne pense pas qu'on y arriverait
par contre je crois qu'on pourrait
trouver un assez ample consensus pour
dire les pouvoirs de cet homme que vous
avez désignés sont beaucoup trop
importants
et la constitution contient trop peu de
clics et qui donne du pouvoir à
l'assemblée pour peser de son poids
regarder pour prendre un exemple
contemporain
nous sommes entrés en guerre au mali à
l'appel du gouvernement malien
on a voté une fois pour y aller après
pendant neuf ans le chef de l'état
décide qu'on reste picon ça va puis
qu'on reste on n'en parle jamais nulle
part donc si vous voulez y a des
pouvoirs qui sont considérables à je
prends l'exemple de la guerre il réunit
le conseil de défense pour qu'on les
mesure dans la crise sanitaire donc je
pense qu'on pourrait avoir un président
élu au suffrage universel mais dans la
fonction serait plus clairement
délimitée bon alors pour régler d'un mot
je suis partisan d'une constituante est
donc cette constituante c'est à elles
avec des gens élus pour ça de définir la
nouvelle règle du jeu mais dans mon
esprit si vous voulez le le fond de la
sphère institutionnelle bien sûr mais
pas seulement dans mon esprit il s'agit
de refonder le peuple français tel qu'il
est devenu
bigarrée
urbain
féminisé et ce peuple là il vit avec des
institutions d'un autre temps dans notre
âge et sur lequel m'a jamais demandé son
ami donc ce serait l'occasion en
écrivant la constitution de se
constituer comme peuple voilà mon idée
est par conséquent j'hésite à vous dire
le prochain régime la 6ème république
sera plutôt ceci ou de cela puisque
c'est le rôle de la constituante de
parmi les millions d'archivés de l'ina
nous avons choisis pour vous une
madeleine
[Musique]
dans votre panthéon personnel
gutenberg ah oui occasion de vous
montrer un très beau reportage télévisé
de 63 sur le travail des imprimeries de
presse
envers du décor le voilà le chef
d'atelier jusque là que puni de la
rédaction il la cote c'est à dire qu'ils
indiquent les caractères dans laquelle
il doit être composé élire mais un
linotypiste
[Musique]
les lieux qui piste va composer le plan
voyez ça ce plan qui font c'est un peu
l'opinion à l'état brut
[Musique]
le plan est apportée dans la forme
il y sera serrée avec les titres et les
clichés
mais cette forme vous constatez place or
les grands journaux utilisent des
rotatives
il que l'on pouvait un moyen d'arrondir
cette forme en prenant une empreinte un
flan
sur une espèce de cartons qui reproduit
complètement la forme et dans cette
forme arrondie au cool ce que vous voyez
là c'est à dire un mot
[Musique]
les dom où seront présentés sur un
cylindre aux rotatives laquelle sera
alimentée avec ses bobines de papier que
vous voyez c'est beau hein
j'ai fait ce boulot à besançon que
j'étais étudiant jeu pour gagner ma vie
je travaillais à l'entreprise neo typo
et j'étais à côté du linotypiste et moi
j'étais censé corriger pas été un
correcteur fameux mais je faisais le
travail vous avez vu la forme plate on
appeler ça une maurras avec de la
ficelle autour c'est pour ça qu'on parle
de textes bien ficelés parce que ont en
effet on mettait de la pucelle oui hélas
ce qui me frappe c'est que dans des
ateliers comme celui qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure vous pouviez avoir jusqu'à 100
ans gars 1 pour faire tout ce qu'ils
avaient à faire aujourd'hui sont cinq ça
passe directement de l'ordinateur sur le
bobino c'est extraordinaire à voir le
progrès l'inventivité technique à leur
alliance a massacré plein de plans de
métier mais bon ça nous montre quand
même quelle qu'elle est là géniaux zitte
et des êtres humains donc je compte
dessus pour la suite une archive que
nous soumettons à tous les candidats
celle de l' alerte verte
[Musique]
extrait de la campagne officielle de 74
votre première présidentielle en tant
que citoyen avec à la télévision un
candidat en pull-over rouge
et vous savez ce qui va se passer bien
nous allons bientôt manquer de l'eau et
c'est pourquoi je bois devant vous un
verre d'eau précieuse puisque avant la
fin du siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera à lundi je
vous dis au revoir et j'espère vous
revoir pour vous expliquer notre projet
global d'avenir merci mes amis tôt
rené dumont j'écris candidat écolo qui
prend un peu de son temps de l'antenne
pour voir ce verre d'eau il poil
regardez nous sommes en 2022 on en parle
il a eu raison mais avant tout le monde
et mais on n'entendait pas il ya 50 ans
non non non non non pas du tout pourquoi
moi je sais que j'ai repris cette
bataille de l'eau parce que je pense que
c'est le prochain ça bien là ça va être
la grosse question pouvez vous passer
tous au dos donc je vais pas vous faire
mes arguments sur le sujet mais à
l'époque ne tombait pas la gauche était
dominée par le productivisme idéologie
qui allait avec si vous voulez on allait
développer les forces productives et on
allait les développer tellement bien
qu'ils auraient pour tout le monde et
donc tout irait bien et tout irait mieux
et on était tous là dedans et on
écoutait pas et quand françois
mitterrand par exemple fait un éditorial
dans le journal du ps les poches pour
s'appeler l'unité alors il a fait un
truc que l'oiseau qui s'étouffe dans
l'air le poisson qui se noie dans la
rivière mais ont éclaté de rire les gens
autour de moi des mais qu'est ce qu'ils
racontent qu'ils aient qu'est ce que
c'est que ce truc les oiseaux qui
s'asphyxie dans l'herbe et pis quoi
encore non il y avait zéro tolérance
zéro écoute et quand il ya eu le
le club de rome alors quand il ya une il
ya eu un club qui s'est fait et en
réaction des intellectuels comme gb
autres au fait l'an zéro bon il
proposait de réduire justement le niveau
delà du productivisme il faut voir ce
qu'on disait à leur sujet qu'on de
l'angoissé des suppôts du capitalisme
ils veulent augmenter le chômage et
faire peur aux travailleurs enfin le
discours était complètement stéréotypé
bloqué paralysé et il a fallu que je me
trouve moi confronté à l'absurdité de ce
qu'on racontait que je me rende compte
que au fond les l'écologie politique
présentait la question du collectivisme
sous l'angle qui m'intéressait c'est à
dire les biens communs l'humanité comme
une seule espèce animale bon et que tout
d'un coup je fasse le lien entre ça et
mon fondamental qui est la philosophie
humaniste et mme évolutionnaire 89
droits de l'homme pour que je comprenne
que tout ça se tenait et que c'est ce
qu'on racontait qui tenait pas avec bon
cette vision absolument c'est du mauvais
prométhéen c'est prométhée exalté parce
que moi tout réglé par en produisant
produisant et en prélevant un quart en
marche on l'avait lu que comme ça
pourtant marx est le premier à dire le
capitalisme épuise l'homme et la nature
mais ça nous intéressait pas à l'époque
voulait pas voir ça pour finir sans
déclenchement d'une rencontre
[Musique]
dans la malle aux trésors de l'ina nous
y avons trouvé pour vous la voix de jean
d'ormesson c'est l'émission présence
protestante en 2002 qui lui demande s'il
a la foi est une formule chi ce que
j'aime beaucoup ni oui ni non bien au
contraire
si vous voulez que je vous résume ça en
un mot je dirais que
d'abord j'aime bien que je ne sais pas
je ne vous avez sûrement beaucoup de
d'abord je suis extraordinairement
respectueux de toutes religions je pense
que la religion
est ce qu a de plus un portail à une
formule qu'il est ni catholique ni
protestant que j'aime infiniment c'est
d'un ennui l'arabe à ce qu'il y a le
plus important c'est dieu
qu'il existe ou qu'il n'existe pas
ça je le crois profondément
donc je crois que plus que toute
politique évidemment que toute
littérature évidemment mais plus même
que l'art probablement ce qui élève
l'homme c'est ce qu'il croit
votre commentaire
je dois faire un commentaire à votre
guise
moi j'ai connu jean d'ormesson à un
moment particulier de sa vie donc j'ai
pas connu l'éditorialiste réactionnaires
qui l'a été pendant des années je l' ai
connu à une époque où s'était détaché de
beaucoup de choses et il s'est créé
entre nous un petit liens de sympathie
amusé de sa part 1 et pour être franche
oui j'ai conçu tout de suite une
beaucoup d'affection pour lui je crois
qu'il ya plein de gens comme moi et puis
il avait un talent humour bon mais c'est
la question vous vrai que je parle de
dieu je préfère pas je suis entouré de
gens croyant je comprends qu'elle
fonction joue la foi la foi n'a pas
besoin de raisonnement
c'est une forme de certitude à laquelle
accède les gens par des canaux
affectif et
penser qu'ils sont très spécifiques si
vous voulez que je me fasse comprendre
plus simplement quand vous écoutez de la
musique dite moi de quoi parle la
musique vous ne savez pas mais vous avez
la certitude que ça parle ça te dit
quelque chose à propos d'une réalité que
seule la musique va exprimer de la même
manière si vous regardez un tableau
abstrait le tableau abstrait vous parle
alors qu'ils ne représentent rien mais
il il vous suggère une harmonie en jeu
des couleurs des formes et votre cerveau
l'interprète dans un registre
plus d'habitude ils n'utilisent pas les
mots ne sont pas tous les maux son book
où il n'ya pas de pensée sans les mots
mais il ya d'autres aspects de la
réalité à laquelle on accède par
d'autres fonctions intellectuelles et
mentale ceux qui accèdent à la fois
n'ont pas besoin de nos raisonnements
étant entouré de gens qui croient que
j'aime et que je respecte
je ne serai plus les mauvaises blagues
de ma jeunesse où nous étions assez
grossièrement anticléricaux au point de
d'être offensant pour ceux qui croyaient
non ça je ne le ferai plus et j'ai adoré
tout ce que tout ce que vient de dire
jean d'ormesson pour essayer de se
sortir de l'impasse dans laquelle vous
venez de le faire
est-ce que ça s'apparente un peu ce que
vous venez de dessiner jean luc
mélenchon aux forces de l'esprit évoqué
par wasa mitterrand lors de ses voeux
aux français oui ça m'a pas choqué au
money gram nous croyons aux forces de
l'esprit oui vous savez vous que
j'admets que j'ai eu un côté un peu il
ya toujours un côté un peu
inconditionnel à l'égard de de françois
mitterrand je m'en amuse parce que si
vous voulez dans le monde politique les
gens sont extrêmement frivole il passe
d'une mode à l'autre il brûle ce qu'ils
ont adoré il adore ce qu'ils ont brûlé
donc si vous voulez quand vous tenez
tête sur la mémoire de françois
mitterrand il ya toujours des moments
agréables c'est que parmi une poignée de
lâches qui disait rien tout d'un coup il
y en a un qui dit moi aussi bon bref
alors quand il a parlé des forces de
l'esprit
je me suis reconnu dans ce qu'ils
disaient je suis incapable de vous dire
ce que ça peut bien vouloir dire mais
je pense comme lui jean luc mélenchon au
terme de cette émission et de ce voyage
dans les archives de l'ina y at il un
morceau essentiel de votre adn que nous
avons manqué je sais pas vous dire
d'abord je commence par vous dire que je
ne me regarde pas vivre
donc je n'ai pas je ne raconte pas mon
histoire je ne fais pas une fresque même
si je considère que construire sa vie on
doit le faire comme on construit une en
la pensant comme une oeuvre d'art comme
comme dit le sociologue
que vous connaissez la construction de
soi se fait pour ce qui me concerne avec
la chance que j'ai eue dans la vie de
rencontrer la possibilité de d'exercer
des responsabilités bon voilà c'est une
histoire qui me lie à la plus petite
poussière de l'humanité donc voilà c'est
spécial mais voyez
bon non je ne me regarde pas vivre ce
que je regrette peut-être après avoir
vous dirais que c'est de la coquetterie
vous cohen parce que vous êtes taquin
mais j'aurais aimé montrer mon évolution
théorique entre un marxisme extrêmement
étroits enfin la vérité c'était hier de
chardin au départ le marxisme ensuite
quand même comme ça et puis toute cette
évolution je faisais rentrée des choses
jusqu'à la théorie de l'ère du peuple et
de la révolution citoyenne mais j'admets
que c'est pas décisif pour ceux qui nous
qui nous écoute mais je veux qu'ils
sachent que je suis comme ça hein je
suis un héritier de quand on n'agit pas
clairement si on ne pense pas clairement
merci jean luc mélenchon
[Musique]